hi everyone today we're gonna talk about
tools but first let me tell you about my
dad my dad was a tool maker and what
that meant in his context was he worked
in a machine shop and he went to school
for an extra year to learn some advanced
techniques so that he could make tools
the tools he made were used to make
parts or make it easier to make parts
that any other machinist could make and
there was two reasons why he was called
a tool maker as opposed to just a
machinist first was that he just went to
school for an extra year and learned
some things
the second was those tools well they
were very important to the manufacturing
process it was they're also very
important to saving time making some of
these parts so I want to think about
that a little bit today is there
anything that we do as developers that
we could save time that could be easier
that we could be more effective at and
to do that let's first discuss how
linters compilers and other cool things
work I'm will Klein I'm from Longmont
Colorado
I work in Boulder as an engineer at
workday and today we're going to talk
about four things first what are our
problems what are the things that we
might be able to think about and improve
second I'm going to talk about compilers
because compilers are just really
awesome and typically you'll only learn
about that and peer science at a
university but I think there's some
really essential things that we can all
gather very quickly today and there's a
key piece of compilers that we're gonna
really dive into and make our best
friend and then we're going to look at
how that key piece can be applied to
those problems and hopefully come up
with some solutions so the first problem
that I run into a lot is with code
review and I don't have a problem code
of you I love code review I've worked in
a really lovely code review rich culture
for the past five years but but there's
some things I see in code review that
could be better
I love getting feedback I love giving
feedback I love asking questions and
learning about code just to the code
review but when something comes up that
is I'll just say tribal knowledge I'll
submit my first PR to a project and
they'll say oh yeah that's great but
when you work in this part of the
codebase there's these other things you
can use that you didn't know about and
here's where they are so there's all
these things that we can only learn from
code review or from pairing with another
developer that I kind of wonder is there
a better way than waiting until we get
to code review to find out about those
things and then going back to the
drawing board or re rewriting our code
and the second thing that is actually
really awesome are changing language
features we have since es6 we have had
so many iterations in the language all
these awesome new features that have
come about but I wonder is there an
easier way to apply those to our
existing code to bring these new awesome
things into our code bases and take
advantage of them without having to
change everything manually and the last
piece is very relate to that API changes
or even changing libraries and
frameworks we've seen plenty of change
and I've largely embraced it and enjoyed
it but when I need to switch from one
library to another and change all the
syntax so potentially hundreds of
changes in the code base and it's just a
lot of tedium and I wonder can we also
improve that cool so to do that we're
gonna take a step over to compiler land
and talk about compilers really briefly
so how do we turn this into something
that the machine can understand how we
turn a variable declaration into ones
and zeros that can be put through the
CPU and have awesome things happen in
our browsers there's a little bit of
magic but hopefully less less of that
after today Babel gives us an awesome
reference point Babel is a type of
compiler that takes in source does some
stuff with it and then spits back out
JavaScript source a transpiler
technically is what type of compiler it
is and it actually has everything we
need to
you to understand compilers and there's
this really awesome definition of a
compiler that I'm going to borrow Jamie
builds on Twitter and github writes this
in the super tiny compiler most
compilers break down into three primary
stages parsing transformation and
cogeneration okay let's dive in each one
parsing is taking raw code turning it
into a more abstract representation of
the code okay it's taking that
JavaScript code and turning into
something else that's more abstract the
second part is transformation that's
taking the abstract representation and
and changing it to do whatever the
compiler wants it to do
so in the case of babel it wants to take
potentially a javascript with es2016
2017-2018 features and so on and do
something with that trees so that when
it spits it back out it's going to be in
something like closer to es 5 that more
browsers can support out of the box and
that's the cogeneration is spitting that
code back out and other compilers might
spit out something else but Babel just
it's JavaScript back out cool so we're
going to focus on one piece of this the
abstract representation because this is
where all the magic that we really care
about happens so going back to our code
example the first thing with parsing
that we mentioned is breaking this down
into tokens and there's just what are
those discrete pieces of code in this
line that stand on their own the atoms
in the molecule and this is just a array
of these tokens but from here we need to
figure out how to relate these tokens to
each other how does the VAR and the
answer bond to each other what are the
what is their connection and the 6 and
the x and the 7 what how are they
related and how does that tie back to
the variable it's being declared so to
do that we need some type of
representation that representation is
called
the ast and ast does not stand for
whatever Marcy said it is actually an
arc abstract syntax tree and that sounds
very a computer science e and or D but
it's just a tree we don't talk about
trees
but we actually work with them a ton the
Dom is probably the best example we have
our HTML document and that has a head
and a body the head has a title and meta
tags and the body has divs and those
divs have their own divs
so what a tree is essentially is just a
node at the top
it's weird trees are like upside down in
computer science world because just the
node of the top there's a root and then
it can have any number of children and
then they can in turn have children and
they can also have properties on them
that describe them so we're gonna look
at this in a just another view in a
moment let me show you something called
ast explore so this is a really awesome
tool that's up at h to explore dotnet
check it out we're gonna play with it
today and show you how it works it's a
little bit tricky to present with though
there's a lot of options and it doesn't
quite scale very well so I made a
special version a Cascadia jason cool so
right here we just have an empty program
file that's the same thing and there's
nothing here but already we have a tree
and right off we can see that it has a
program node this is the root node in
every program every file that's that's
parsed and it has three types of
properties that we're going to talk
about the first is its type and every
every node always has a type and this
will differ program at the top here and
the second type of property is where the
children live in this case there's a
body there's nothing there yet but there
will be and the third type is a
descriptive property describing that
node itself in this case it's describing
it as a source type of module alright
let's look at another example
let's look at those variables again so
now we can see that the program has two
children it has two elements here if we
expand that they are our two variable
declarations asu's are awesome and
Cascadia Jess is love so the first
available declaration there's a little
bit of a hint here say in the grey
saying hey as a typist
and as kind so the type we're familiar
with the declarations this is what the
children look like on a variable
declaration there could be more than
once there's just one here it also has a
kind and the kind is kind of cool
because it's describing whether it's a
Const or a let which the VAR that looks
pretty familiar let's dive deeper down
the rabbit hole for a moment looking at
the variable declared er this has two
properties besides the type it has an ID
and an it doesn't have any descriptive
properties but it's got two places where
children live it's good it has its
identifier for a STS and then it
initializes that to this string little
for awesome so every node in the ast for
JavaScript looks like this the node type
might be a little bit different its
children might live in a different place
or it might not have children and I
might have different descriptive
properties but every node in JavaScript
and the ast can be related to this
example let's take it one step further
so I was talking about automating code
reviews before who here has seen code
like this who has seen code like this on
one line yeah that's a lot of hands yeah
so tools like es line are great for this
to look for patterns and language and
help us help us warn us when we're doing
things we probably shouldn't we're gonna
write insolent role for this so I'm
gonna go over to transform on ESP
explorer and pull up the latest version
of Uslan and let me explain this for a
moment so every is lint roll is
essentially a function this function
returns an object this object is where
you can say hey whenever there's a note
of a given type I care about that and
whenever you find it yes lint passed
that into my function here so this
example is looking for temple literals
we don't have any what do we care about
here let me go back to the Explorer if I
click here cool so I see conditional
expression a bunch of times
pretty sure that's what turn Aries are
called so that's the type so let's grab
that and let's yell if anyone uses a
ternary cool so over on this bottom
right we see that it's hade you have a
turn right here you have turnout here
there's three turn Aries awesome
cool I don't need Turner's that much I
think they're great when they're
appropriate and they're just a single
one so let's narrow this down and
everyone will do this they'll say hey I
care about this note type but I'm gonna
look for a pattern and so what do we
need to look for so we talked about
being nested and that's where the the
node is the node of the same type is on
the on the child and there's three
things on this node there's the test
this is the condition it executes and if
that conditions truthy it returns the
consequent if it's false it returns the
alternate these consequence and these
alternates these are the children we
care about and these are the ones that
have that nested type so oh lord what
happened to the bottom there it is okay
so let's grab that we need to write a
check just a little bit logic here so we
need to look at the node and look at its
consequent and check its type and if it
equals a conditional expression or if we
copy this if that alternate is a
conditional expression
that's a little bit smaller Oh Lord
don't don't no no don't leave five codes
it's fine I'll just give a quick reload
it is crashing hard cool we make this
bigger again cool so I just have to fix
a little bit of code here my cursor is
like not where I think it is it's not
prettier there it goes oh yeah this is
not because of ASC xplornet this is cuz
I hacked this like in the past week
instead of working on my presentation at
like the wrong hours of the day cool so
so now we're looking for a conditional
expression on either of the children and
now it's only warning us about one thing
and this is actually in fact the
insolent rule for nested turn Aries
let's look at one more example let's
look at transforms so focus up here for
a minute and we have two objects they're
essentially the same when you have the
key and the value is the the same thing
in this case X they can be represented
as X : X or in a shorthand version
that's just X super convenient what I
would like to do is try to implement the
Babel transform that would make this
first one with the shorthand output the
same so we want to change this part in
the bottom right if we look at a Babel
transform the boilerplate is a little
bit different there's a function that
returns an object again but that object
has a name and a visitor this visitor is
actually the same as that object in the
eslint so we're going to dive into that
it cares about an identifier right now
in the boilerplate it's reversing the
the identifiers making them backwards
that's funny so let's change that to be
what do we need to be so if we look at X
try this again
well we got this and never seen this
happen of course it's live so if I look
at this we've got an object expression
this is the object itself
it's got properties okay the properties
the object property has a short head
value this is the descriptive property
that we care about and it's false right
now so what do we need to do we first
need to care about object properties
it's not prettier we first need to care
about object properties and then when we
run into them we need to do something
with that node so that node has the
shorthand value and we can just set it
to be false so is it was true before on
the other one and now we're changing it
to false now the output matches there's
one more thing we don't want to do this
for my lord we don't want to do this for
for every node so what we normally do is
to student if check and check the path
no touch for him if it's true thee only
then mutate the tree cool all right so
that is actually the all there is to the
object property or the object shorthand
property transform in Babel and this is
a plug-in in the insolent not the
insolent the babble plug in the source
code stop here for a moment because this
concept of transforming the tree and
outputting something else also applies
to another tool called code mods with
code mods are is taking in some syntax
and changing it to some updated syntax
so we talked about new a new features in
JavaScript and we talked about API
changes and changing libraries and
frameworks we could do transforms like
this to take old syntax that we want to
update and automate the conversion
across our code base to the newer syntax
there's one more thing I'll point you to
this is website that just put up
yesterday called a STS are awesome comm
and it has full background of everything
we've been talking about with links to
examples super setting the compilers in
there and some other things so check it
out after this
for more information cool
so I know we all heard neo say and the
matrix I know kung fu
but if Neil is a programmer and the
matrix is essentially made of code and
he's bending the matrix to as well what
I think he really meant to say is I know
some really sick ast transforms try it
pull up ast xplornet and start typing
code paste stuff from from your project
and see what it looks like
and the next time you're in code review
and you see something like oh I need to
tell you about this thing that you
couldn't otherwise know about think
about whether that was that can be
discerned filtered down into a pattern
that you can automate that you can write
in the estimate rule for here's actually
the first es lint rule I wrote was for
this code we had this API request
function that would get data from the
server and it had a way of saying how
many records it wanted to retrieve you
know maybe like 50 or 100 something
reasonable but we had cases in our code
base that looked passed in the count of
infinity which would get all the records
and that sounds okay right
except users with lots of data you know
our big customers that love us so much
they would make this request on in the
browser and it would take forever and
after three seconds in a timeout and
they would just get a really bad screen
that didn't help them at all
so we we need to fix this but we had
something like sixty plus developers in
the front end code across all the teams
and this was like a it's kept popping up
here and there and we could tell
everyone but like how do you just like
tell everyone and then tell the new
person all that so we automated this so
we wrote an excellent rule that looked
for any invocations the API dot request
and looked at the parameters passed in
and then looked at that that
configuration object and looked at the
count and made sure it was something
reasonable and if it was something crazy
like infinity we would warn them nicely
before code review
let's talk about API changes can we
automate those we had been using
glamorous in a project time on now and
this is basically styled components CSS
and Jas actually is great great lately
and Kent C Dodds he we talked about him
yesterday he worked on this and he was
the first to say hey everyone
glamorous this glamorous is great but
emotions even better we should just
deprecated and move to that so we have
lots of CSS lots of components we've got
to change everything in our code base
and it looks something like this this is
just glamorous takes in some some CSS
and generates an element with that style
applied we need to change the syntax
from using glamorous to using styled and
instead of taking an object and it
needed to be passed a string literal
which is great because then you just
write real CSS and not like JavaScript
to fly it turned out there was a
community effort to transform all the
instances of glamorous to emotion we
applied this in our code base and change
hundreds of wines and just a click of a
button and it was fantastic cool let me
tell you one more story
I was at a Jess coffe in Florida just
conf u.s. 2015 and there was a young
developer they got on stage and he was
telling his story and we're something
like this there was this new thing
called es6 there was a large gap of my
knowledge on parsers compilers and
generally the intricacies of JavaScript
so I decided to make an es6 transpiler
to learn it called six-to-five this was
Sebastian McKenzie and 65 is now known
as Babel now I am not encouraging you
all to go out write your own compiler we
don't need to but given Babel given is
lint given some libraries for code mods
and given equivalents and typescript we
don't have to we can build plug-ins for
these tools we can write our own
limiting plugins that look like what I
showed you we can write transforms that
can update our code we can harness the
ast and I encourage everyone here this
is something for you to try I'm here to
answer questions on the internet or
after this I encourage you all to build
your own tools to help you and help
everyone else the right JavaScript be
more effective JavaScript developers my
name is will Klein I'm on twitter at
wills lab thank you very much